حين لا تسلم اسرائيل جثامين الشهداء
الفلسطينيين فهي تضعهم في مقابر خاصه بها
يطلق عليها اسم مقابر الارقام ذلك لان
اسرائيل تتعمد عدم كتابه اسماء الشهداء
عليها وتضع عبادا عن ذلك ارقامه في هذه
المقابر المصنفه مناطق عسكريه تحتجز سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي جاثامين الشهداء
وتتخذ منها احيانا ورقه تفاضيه
لاسترداد جثامين الشهداء والكشف عن مصير
المفقودين للجزيره ان اسرائيل تحتجز مئه
وسبعه عشر شهيدا و شهيدا في ثلاجات الموتى
منذ عام 2015 كما قالت ان من بين الجثامين
خمس نساء شهيدات موزعات بين ثلاجات الموتى
وما يعرف بمقابر الارقام في اسرائيل حيث
لا تزال سلطات الاحتلال تحتاج ذو ايضا 256
ينضم الينا من رام الله عصام العروري ممثل
الحمله الوطنيه لاسترداد الجثامين الشهداء
ومدير مركز القدس للمساعدات القانونيه
اهلا بك ما هي المبردات التي تسوقها
اسرائيل لعدم تسليم جثامين الشهداء
الفلسطينيين
تتغير ضرائع سلطات الاحتلال لاحتجاز
فيتامين الشهداء
وهذه السياسه ليست جديده همم ليست فقط منذ
عام 2015
مارستها وتمارسها منذ قيامها وممارستها
بعد احتلال عام 67 وهناك جتامين شهداء مضى
على الاحتجازها الان اكثر من 50 عاما
وتتغير الضرائع وتتغير هذه السياسات في
المرحله الاخيره هناك قرار سياسي وقضائي
في دوله الاحتلال باحتلال سائر جثامين
الشهداء حتى استعاده طروفات والاسرى
الاسرائيليين همم من الجيش الاحتلال همم
اثر الاعتداءات الاخيره على قطاع غزه
واجازت المحكمه كما اجازه المستوى السياسي
اعتبار الجثامين او ورقه للمساومه ولتحقيق
مقابلها وهذا ما
وحتى صحيفه هارتس الاسرائيليه بانه متاجره
بجثامين الموتى باعتبارك ممثلا للحمله
الوطنيه لاسترداد جثامين الشهداء ما
الخطوات التي تقومون بها في هذا الاطار
نحن نعمل على على عده اصعده كان احدها
القضاء الاسرائيلي ولكن هذا القضاء بات
مغلقا الان بعد ان اجازه المحكمه كما
ذكرنا المحكمه العليا وهي اعلى مرجع قضائي
في دوله الاحتلال اجازه سياسه احتجاجتها
من الشهداء رغداء رغم عدم وجود قانون يسمح
بذلك وانما بموجب قرار سياسي ايدته
المحكمه همم حتى ان قرار احتجاز اخر جثمان
وهو جثمان الشهيد ناصر ابو حميد اخذ بقرار
من وزير الحرب الاسرائيلي همم
ولذلك بدانا بتدويل هذه القضيه حيث تم
توجيه مجموعه من الرسائل للامم المتحده
والمقربين الخواص فيها ويجري حاليا اعداد
ملف لتقديم بلاغ ل- اا محكمه جرائم الحرب
باعتبار ان هذه الجريمه تشكل مخالفه
للقانون الدولي الانساني الذي يفترض ان
تلتزم به سلطات الاحت هل في تعاملها مع
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وعلى صعيد ثالث هناك
همم اعمال الاحتجاجيه التي يقوم بها اهالي
الشهداء مدعومين من المؤسسات الفلسطينيه
والقوه الوطنيه والاسلاميه
والتي كان اخرها اليوم
وفيما مضى كانت تحركات اهالي الشهداء
تقتصر على وقفات في همم مراكز المدن
الفلسطينيه او في مقررات اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر ولكن قرروا من الان فصاعدا
ان يتجهوا الى نقاط التماس مع جنود
الاحتلال لرفع كلفه الاحتجاز بالجامين حيث
انه اذا كان يراد ان تكون عقوبه رادعه وان
تساهم في همم في اخداع الشعب الفلسطيني
فانها قد تتحول الى همم احدى القضايا التي
تؤدي الى تاجيج الاوضاع على الارض
وقد يؤدي ذلك الى ارقام سلطات الاحتلال
على اعاده النظر في هذه السياسه
بتحرير هذه الجهويه من رام الله عصام
العروضي ممثل الحمله الوطنيه لاسترداد
جثامين الشهداء ومدير مركز القدس
للمساعدات القانونيه شكرا جزيلا لك